so i recently came across a story that i
thought was really wild but also
somewhat disturbing and i wanted to
share it with you
it's about johannes kepler but it's also
about his elderly mother katharina the
birth of science fiction and our
reluctance to be open-minded
kepler was a great german astronomer
from the 17th century
his name pops up in plenty of textbooks
today for his laws of planetary motion
he lived in an era where there was no
clear distinction between astronomy and
astrology but there was a strong
division between astronomy and physics
people thought that the planets moved by
only the hand of god kepler himself
wrote plenty of horoscopes but he also
became the first person to combine the
math of predicting eclipses with a
physical explanation
he showed that the movements we can see
can be explained by physical forces
at this time pretty much everyone
believed incorrectly that the sun
revolved around the earth and that the
earth was the center of the universe
it's a fair enough belief because that's
what it feels like
so it's easy to see how an uneducated
guess might go wrong
but kepler was an astronomer and he was
starting to realize that the evidence
pointed towards a very different
conclusion
it pointed towards the heliocentric
model presented by copernicus where the
sun is at the center of the solar system
and we revolve around it
kepler was a university student when he
learned about the copernican theory and
he even wrote his dissertation about it
but the uni kept it kind of harsh
galileo later wrote to kepler to confess
that he was also a believer in the
copernican model but he hadn't dared to
stand up for it in public yet and he
wouldn't for another 30 years
you might have heard about how that
ended up for galileo he was tried before
the catholic church and sentenced to
spend the rest of his life under house
arrest it was in 1616
that an inquisition declared
heliocentrism
to be foolish and absurd and to
contradict the holy scripture
they decided it was punishable by death
the same time as galileo's trial kepler
was rushing to try and save his mother
who was facing a trial of her own for an
equally if not more hated crime
witchcraft
but all of these events are somewhat
connected in an unexpected way
years earlier in 1609 kepler had
finished writing a book called somnium
or the dream
it is often called one of if not the
first example of science fiction writing
because of how much hard science it
contained
before i take a look at the story i
would like to quickly thank audible for
sponsoring this video
the story that i'm sharing today about
kepler is one that i read about in the
first chapter of the book figuring by
maria popova
it is one of the most poetic retellings
of scientific ideas and of the human
search for truth and meaning i've been
listening to it on audible which is nice
because i can listen to it in bed before
i fall asleep audible has a huge library
of audio books but also podcasts guided
wellness programs and performances
pretty much anything spoken
as a member you get one credit every
month to redeem for any title that you
get to keep forever but they also now
have the plus catalog so even if you've
spent your credits there are still
thousands of titles included that you
can always download i'm happy to
recommend audible because it is
something that i use already in my daily
life so it makes a lot of sense for me
to share it with you new members can
always try audible for free for 30 days
and as we're approaching christmas there
is also a limited time offer to save 60
on your first three months which works
out to only 5.95 a month you can get
that by going to audible.com
tippies or for those in the us you can
text tibi's to 500-500
so here's the story originally written
in latin it starts with kepler falling
asleep and he has a dream in which he's
reading a book in that book we have the
story of an icelandic boy called
duracotis he's 14 years old and his
mother makes a living selling mysterious
bags of herbs with mystical markings on
them she sells them to ship captains for
good luck
one day duracotus cuts open one of the
bags to see what's inside and spills the
contents out everywhere
his mother is really angry with this
because it loses her money so instead
she agrees to give her son to the
skipper in place of one of the bags and
they take off together and sail to
norway on the ocean voyage jiracotis
becomes seasick and so the captain
leaves him behind on land with
instructions to go and deliver something
to the astronomer tycho ibrahim
durakotis ends up becoming a student of
the astronomer and spends five years in
his care learning how to observe the
heavens
take this drawing with a grain of salt
because this book was actually written
before galileo pointed the first spy
glass at the sky and before kepler
himself had ever looked through a
telescope
after a few years duracoates travels
back to iceland to meet up with his
mother she's happy to hear that he has
studied astronomy and reveals that she
too possesses lots of knowledge on this
topic but then she reveals that the
reason she has this knowledge is because
she is able to summon up these spirits
or demons which can move her anywhere on
earth in an instant it turns out this
doesn't just include the earth though
because she summons one of her favorite
spirits to speak with them the spirit
tells them that 50 000 miles up in the
ether lies the island of levania which
is earth's moon the spirits are able to
take humans up to the moon in a journey
of four hours
apparently the journey is a shock to
humans so they are sedated with drugs
for the trip the spirit describes a trip
to the moon and also talks a lot about
the earth which is called vulva the name
is picked carefully to represent
revolution or
revolving as for the inhabitants of the
moon they believe that the earth rotates
around the moon
vulva goes through the same phases that
we see the moon go through
the moon levania is also divided into
two hemispheres one is called pre-vulva
which never sees the earth it is the
side of the moon that is always locked
facing away from us and the other
hemisphere is sub-vulva which does see
the earth as their moon
a lot of the book is then a very
detailed scientific description of how
the earth would look from the moon
how eclipses would look the size and
orbits of planets and even some
descriptions of creatures that inhabit
the moon
now at the time this was written the
idea that the moon revolved around the
earth was actually well known and
non-controversial
kepler is trying to suggest that perhaps
our own certainty about earth's fixed
position in space with regards to the
sun
is just as misguided as the lunar
citizens belief that the earth revolves
around them
when you're standing on the moon and the
ground feels firm and motionless beneath
your feet and you see this pale blue dot
of the earth rising and setting against
your horizon you can really be convinced
in something that's not true
the story was written 300 years before
edwin abbott's flatland and in that book
we are exposed to creatures that live in
one-dimensional and two-dimensional
spaces and we see how it is utterly
impossible to convince them that there
exists a third dimension in flatland the
reader is left questioning whether there
must be some obvious fourth dimension
that we are also incapable of
comprehending kepler hoped that by
seeing the absurdity of the lunar
people's belief that the moon was at the
center of the universe that we ourselves
would have the insight to question
whether that was true for us as well
he wanted to gently expose more people
to copernicus's theory of the solar
system but he knew it would be too
complex and abstract to just present the
scientific facts to a largely
scientifically illiterate public
instead he knew that storytelling was an
amazing way to share science that still
remains true today kepler perhaps knew
that the universe is made of stories not
atoms
it's quite convoluted how kepler
presents the events as being within a
book within a dream and it creates quite
a lot of distance between kepler and
what he's writing down perhaps that is
deliberate as a way to be able to deny
and say that these are not necessarily
things that he believes the
old-fashioned retweets are not
endorsements it was called the dream but
the story was supposed to awaken people
to a new scientific truth
however it turned out that society was
in a slumber too deep to be helped
sometime in 1611 the manuscript got
leaked but the science and symbolism
were lost on the illiterate
superstitious and vengeful villages of
kepler's hometown
it was taken to be more of an
autobiography
since there were a few facts hard to
ignore
it was well known that kepler himself
had been an apprentice of tycho ibrahim
and kepler's mother was a herb doctor
just like the mother figure in the story
so when their fictional mother character
conjured up spirits to travel to the
moon that was taken literally so
apparently a local woman who was already
angry at katharina over a private matter
heard of the book and used it as
ammunition to convince 24 others in the
town to testify that katharina was a
witch these accounts were as random as a
man dating the onset of his disability
to a night 10 years earlier when he had
taken a single sip from a cup at
catharina's house
kepler took on his mother's legal
defense and dedicated six years of his
life to disproving each of these
allegations using science to point to
natural causes behind each one
but his mother was arrested and taken
from her home in the middle of the night
the accounts i've read say that the
dream wasn't presented as evidence at
the trial but kepler did hold himself at
least partially responsible for her fate
having written it katharina was
imprisoned for 14 months and threatened
with torture but confessed nothing
eventually she was released but never
recovered and died not long after kepler
spent the rest of his life obsessively
annotating the dream with
223 footnotes as long as the story
itself his intention was to dispel
superstitious interpretations by giving
his exact scientific reasons for using
each symbol and metaphor
he says in footnote number eight if any
of you have read this little book before
you will understand what forebodings
this book brought me
he says these words were taken up by
senseless spirits and finally burned
forth into a rumor blown up by ignorance
and experience
he takes particular care with describing
the spirits in the book and in footnote
34 he says that they are the spirits of
science to whom the causes of things are
known there are nine of them metaphysics
physics ethics astronomy astrology
optics music geometry and arithmetic he
also talks about his ideas of gravity
and keep in mind this is before newton
is even born
foot note 66 says i define gravity as a
power similar to magnetic force a mutual
attraction the force of this attraction
is greater in bodies close to each other
rather than in those that are remote as
a consequence they rather resist
separation from one another when they
are still close to each other in the
very next footnote he demonstrates an
intuitive understanding of inertia again
this is before newton would pin it down
in one of his laws
kepler says because bodies are heavy
they resist motion
kepler tried to publish the dream in
1629 but ran out of money
he traveled a hundred kilometers on a
horse to repay debts and try to sell his
assets to finish printing the book but
on his journey he came down with an
illness and died in 1630
the dream was published in 1634 by
kepler's son ludwig for kepler it seems
that his search for truth came at a
great personal cost
the idea that the earth was not the
center of the universe was the first
major challenge to our self-importance
and each challenge since has faced
similar resistance
300 years later we would use kepler's
laws to calculate a trajectory to the
moon and land there allowing kepler's
dream to come
true thanks for watching this video and
thanks to my patreon supporters for
making it possible a special shout out
to today's patreon cat of the day jojo
[Music]
you